to celebrate the mathematical constant
of Pi we're going to attempt the most
accurate calculation ever of Pi using
PI's
now before we do our PI based PI
calculation will have a quick crash
course in circles and why PI are so
important now to do that because we're
in the UK home of many famous circles
we'll come to on the oldest and greatest
circles which is of course this one it's
the football circle here at Knott County
Football Club apparently they are the
world's oldest football league club
it's a giant sign that says that right
behind me oh it doesn't mean for a while
there I guess they had no one else to
play but you know who knows so this
circle here as you can see there's two
things going on with the circle first of
all there's the diameter so it's this
nice wonderful straight line here that
goes right through the middle of the
circle and the great thing about a
diameter is it's a nice straight line so
if I wanted to I could get a measuring
tape and I could measure from the start
all the way across here to the finish
and get a very precise measurement of
the distance across the circle now
around here we have the circumference
now this is a lot harder to measure as
you can see it's a curved line so
instead of having to measure it directly
we can use pi now pi is the ratio of the
straight line diameter to the total
distance all the way around the outside
and if we know that ratio we can do one
measurement for the diameter multiply it
by PI and get the exact distance all the
way around the outside right enough
messing around on a football pitch let's
go get up eyes out all right the first
thing we need actually we were talking
to the guy who does the circle on the
pitch for the football stadium here and
he does it the same way I think most
people do gets a bit of string makes the
middle bit of the string remain
perfectly still and what will become the
center of the circle and then use that
to draw a nice equal distance line all
the way around in fact I guess that's
the best way to define a circle is the
line of all the points the same distance
away from a center point the center
point will be my pen and the outside
will be the chalk
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's do this my goal is to
not actually do any measurements other
than using pi so the entire thing is
gonna be pi base we get the
circumference and an exact number of
PI's can take we get the diameter a
number of PI's divide one by the other
we get pi pi was historically really
calculated this way because it's
notoriously inaccurate to try and get I
know where it is it's adversely
inaccurate to try and calculate pi by
measuring a circle
[Music]
to get any kind of accuracy on our final
answer we are to be as precise as we can
be this is a mild problem because I want
to go from from the very edge of the
circle but as you can see I've
positioned all the pies exactly on the
line as if there are little mini
tangents so I'm going to have to move
these two out and then I can start doing
the diameter exactly on the
circumference there like that
[Music]
that's 84 264 and 2/3 pies around we
know the diameter is 84 and 1/3 pi to
get pi we just divide the circumference
by the diameter okay and if we actually
work out what that is equals PI from
PI's we got three point one three eight
three four which is approximately 3.14
so using PI's we've got PI to be 3.14 we
I have a very happy man right now I
anything between 3.1 and 3.2 I would
have been happy but to get 3.14 I'm
downright ecstatic so there you are that
is officially the world's most accurate
calculation of pi using PI's it wasn't
really something we planned to make part
of the video but there's a lot of you
have asked the PI's we use were donated
and were no longer fit for human
consumption so we couldn't give them to
charity like we did for example with all
the baked beans that Heinz donated us
earlier however in the spirit of pi day
we did attempt to make some kind of
gesture and we donated 314 pounds of
course 314 to a local charity here and
nottingham that helps give food to
people in times of crisis now a lot of
you have expressed a lot of interest in
charity and we'd really encourage you if
you're in a position to do so to also
make a donation and we've put some links
under the video and because we're all
number files here why not make your
donation a multiple of Pi in some way
being 18 to the length L okay and that
means that the distance here is too old
okay